is it possible that the story is the
primary living organism not the
Storyteller
so
that somehow humans uh Homo sapiens
evolved to become these like hosts for a
more intelligent living organism which
is the idea and the ideas are the ones
that are doing the competing so this is
one of the
sort of big perspectives behind your
work that's really revolutionary how
you've seen history but do you ever kind
of uh take out the perspective of the
ideas as the organisms versus the humans
it's
saying about it on the one hand
s absolutely if you look long term in
history it's all the people die it's the
stories that compete and survive and
spread and stories often spread by
making people willing to sacrifice
sometimes their lives for the story
um you know we know in Israel this is
one of the most important story
factories in human history and this is a
place where people still kill each other
every day over stories I don't know if
you've been to Jerusalem right so people
like Jerusalem Jerusalem Jerusalem you
go there I live in Jerusalem in much of
my life you go there it's an ordinary
place you know it's a town you have
buildings you have Stones you have trees
you have dogs and cats and pedestrians
it's a regular place
but then you have the stories about the
place oh this is the place where God
revealed himself this is the place where
Jesus was this is the place was Muhammad
was and it's the stories that people
fight over nobody is fighting over the
stones
people are fighting about the stories
about the stones
and the stories if if a story can get
millions of people to fight for it
um it not only survives it spreads it
can take over the world the other side
of the coin
is that the stories are not really alive
because they don't feel anything this
goes back to the question of
Consciousness which I think is the most
important thing that
the Ultimate Reality
is consciousness is the ability to feel
things if you want to know whether the
hero of some story is real or not you
need to ask can it suffer
um stories don't feel anything
countries which are also stories Nations
don't suffer if a nation loses a war it
doesn't suffer the soldiers suffer the
civilians suffer animals can suffer you
have an army with horses and whatever
and the horses get wounded the horses
suffer the nation can't suffer it's just
in a it's just an imagination it's just
a fictional story in our mind
he doesn't feel anything similarly when
a bank goes bankrupt or a company goes
bankrupt or when a
currency loses its value like Bitcoin is
worth now zero crashed or the dollar is
worth zero it crashed the dollar doesn't
feel anything
it's the people holding the dollars who
might be now very miserable
so we have this
complex situation when history is
largely driven by stories
but stories are not the Ultimate Reality
the Ultimate Reality is is feeling
feelings of humans of animals and the
tragedy of History
is it very very often we get it we get
the order wrong stories are not bad
stories are tools
they are good when we use them in order
to alleviate suffering
but very often we forget it we instead
of using the stories for our purposes we
allow the stories to use us for their
purposes and then you start in tile Wars
because of a story you inflict Millions
suffering on millions of people just for
the sake of a story and that's the
tragedy of human history so the
fundamental property of life
of a living organism is the capacity to
feel and the the ultimate feeling is
suffering you know to
note it's a very difficult question
yeah but when you suffer you know yes
and also in in ethical terms it's more
important to be aware of sufferings than
of any other emotion if you're doing
something which is causing all kinds of
emo all kinds of emotions to all kinds
of people first of all you need to
notice if you're causing a lot of
suffering to someone
if some people are like it and some
people are bothered by it and some
people are a bit angry in you and some
people are suffering because of what you
do you first of all have to note oh now
sometimes you still have to do it you
know the world is a complicated place I
don't know you have an epidemic uh
governments decide to have all that
social isolation regulations or whatever
so in certain cases yes you need to do
it even though it can cause tremendous
suffering but you need to be very aware
of the cost and to be very very you have
to ask yourself again and again and
again is it worth it is it still worth
it
and uh the interesting question there
implied in your statements is that
suffering is a pretty good component of
a touring test for Consciousness this is
the most the most important thing to ask
about AI can suffer
I can suffer then it is an ethical
subject and it needs protection it needs
rights just like humans and animals